but then when you go to Kentucky where a
judge ordered a man to wear a
gps-enabled ankle bracelet because he
had been ordered to quarantine he had
been in contact with somebody who had
been infected and he kept violating it
so the solution here was let's literally
put an electronic tracker on your ankle
and therefore we'll know if you leave
quarantine or it just feels like the
lawyers are gonna have a field day with
this stuff once it's all over yeah I I
hope they do while I hate that we're in
a litigious era of society and I think
that is another way that we're kind of
eroding I'm all for anytime you enact a
new law or set a new precedent an old
one has to go away you know like anytime
you keep adding on to this like you get
this count compounded j-curve and then
this exponential growth of law happens
and then ultimately everything comes
crashing down because you know that's a
different conversation
yeah bunch of problems the first is that
when you start looking as these these
these individual examples and use that
as leverage to hold a greater group of
people responsible that those are
incidental examples that they're like
that is not a representation of the
greater community all right the greater
community is trying to do the right
thing but when you take individual
examples and use that an individual
example to circumvent law and then try
to take the larger population and erode
their freedoms or their rights because
of one idiot
and the greater people are letting that
happen yeah you can just get used to
more the same because once they do it a
few times they'll continue to do it
every single Avenue and an aspect that
they can that they can grab yeah and
this is where I think you get kind of
this intersection of the personal
responsibility and the freedom right
what I mean by that is like you and I
are relatively young relatively healthy
compared to others and therefore we have
the responsibility to ensure those in
our lives
are taken care of but also you're taking
risk if you outside today and you
contract coronavirus right that's a
choice you made
you got infected and you have to deal
with the ramifications and so I think
that there's this debate across society
right at what point are you endangering
other people versus just endangering
yourself and when you overlay the
personal responsibility most people
actually are doing the right thing but
these you know I call them like there's
stupidity and there's just douchebags
and being stupid or being a douchebag
isn't illegal it's just you're stupid or
you're a douchebag and so how you try to
balance that in society is it through
social pressure right or is it actually
where people eventually just turn is how
I am so fearful but I'm willing to give
up my freedom because I want to keep
those people in their apartments in
their homes etc it's just a really
really kind of bad conversation when
people aren't optimizing for the
freedoms because they're so overrun with
the feet yeah I I think that you should
fear is the worst emotion ever to base
decisions about freedoms off of right
and when we're so individual
responsibility is it my choice to go
outside yes and the idea of individual
responsibility is so I'm a libertarian
like nothing crazy libertarian maybe a
little bit but I believe that nobody
should have a say in what I do unless
what I do affects somebody else
negatively and so if I go out and I get
Corona
that's that's that's my problem where
Corona gets kind of gray hazy is because
there's the number of asymptomatic
people that there are where you can
contract Corona and I don't know that I
have true and I can still go transmit to
other people so I'm negatively impacting
other people so under this idea of kind
of individual responsibility I can't
just have the consequences for my
actions just happened to me because
supposedly and I'm putting a little
asterisk
supposedly 1/5 25% of people are
asymptomatic so I could if I don't know
go out and spread it to other what is I
I think an element that people aren't
considering is the beauty of capitalism
and how capitalism can really be the the
equal the equalizer to this conversation
where if you're calling them douchebags
or a selfish person if you are seeing a
business or a person that you don't like
what they're doing you get to vote with
your dollars and that shapes the success
and failure of that business and I think
a lot of people have looked at
entrepreneurs people like me who have
been saying we are not thinking about
the second third order effects of this
pandemic because what I'm balancing is
the cost of lives versus what is the
number of people that are gonna die from
the virus so that's gonna be whatever
hundreds of thousands of people that
might potentially and who those people
are versus the other group of people in
the second and third order effects that
could die from the not from the virus
but from the second third or effects so
you shut down I'm just going to use
Disneyland as an example so you shut
down Disneyland Disneyland employees
let's just say a hundred thousand people
of those hundred thousand people how
many of those people had any savings in
their bank accounts not very much the
average American has about four hundred
dollars in his savings account his or
her savings account so that's not enough
to pay for one month run so if this goes
on for more than one month they can't
pay their rent so we fortunately are
able to I say fortunately asterisks we
can freeze evictions and bankruptcies so
me as a landlord I can't kick somebody
out because they're not paying me but I
know that they still will be paying me
and that person knows that that tally is
continuing to grow and that hole that
they're in economically is going to
continue to get deeper
not socioeconomic conditions are one of
the largest influences to suicide to
depression and to drug abuse so the poor
somebody gets the more often you see
depression
you see suicide and you see drug drug
and alcohol abuse the percentage of
suicide grows as does so the more drug
abuse and alcohol abuse or is the more
socioeconomically disadvantaged somebody
is the more likely they are to have
suicide
so now as this pendulum is swinging and
the second and third order effects of
people losing their homes after they've
lost their job the business is not going
to come back you know gum the McDonald's
that was on the corner it was already
barely making enough money as it was now
they're definitely not not going to be
making enough money they're just not
gonna Rio
you know McDonald's is gonna relocate to
a different place or maybe not in them
right Chipotle not going to open they're
gonna pick and choose where these new
well what stores are gonna be opening
that is gonna have a profound economic
effect and those people that have been
were destitute before now they're truly
struggling so it actually hurt my
feelings a little bit when I looked at
your comments when when you asked what
questions would we ask and one of the
guys said why is tim kennedy so
insensitive to the kind of like the
minorities or outliers of society truth
be told the second third or effects are
gonna be more damaging to those people
than anybody else so if you if you
really strategically and economically
look at what i'm trying to do and how
i'm trying to save lives in this
conversation that we're having we could
seriously be losing way more people
through suicide drug drug overdoses and
alcohol abuse and the kids that are
gonna be homeless then like we know what
happens when somebody loses their home
like how hard it is to get back off of
the street now you're gonna have how
many kids that are gonna be homeless
like nobody's even started to calculate
the economic effect of these second
third order problems I mean we're
talking way more than one or two hundred
thousand people way more you know we're
talking up into the millions
this trajectory of what we're doing to
our economy continues so this isn't an
economy versus live conversation this is
a lives versus lives conversation and
then what is what are those lives gonna
look like regarding freedoms that are
gonna be eroded during the snatch so
there's there's this is a complex
nuanced problem and people are just
making it oversimplifying and like oh
it's lives versus economy no it's not no
it is not don't don't call me like this
hypocrite that I'm being an [ __ ] just
because I'm bringing up the economy I'm
bringing up the economy because I'm
trying to save lives because I know what
happens look at Venezuela and ask how
many lives have been lost when the the
platform the the strategic solution to
this economic disaster is socialism